Boudicca was an ancient Celtic warrior Queen
who lead an army in a rebellion against the
Roman Empire.
The story of this brave woman’s life has
often been reduced to just a few sentences
in a textbook, and that’s because there
is very little known about her life.
There were just two Roman historians; Tacitus
and Cassius Dio, who wrote down information
about Boudicca.
So everything we know about her is skewed
from the enemy’s perspective, and both of
their versions of the story vary slightly
from the other.
But, even from this biased standpoint, we
can still see her bravery and determination
to protect her people.
Despite the fact that we know so little about
her life, she has still made a massive impact,
and very nearly defeated one of the largest
empires in the world.
She is still remembered to this day as being
an epic hero in British history.
Boudicca, and the Celtic People
The term “Celt” is used to refer to the
ancient people of the United Kingdom, but
it covers the Gaels, Britons, and Gauls, just
to name a few.
There were dozens of different independent
tribes that were not united.
So, while their lifestyles were often very
similar, they each had their own customs,
languages, and traditions.
So the name “Celt” is just a way for historians
to refer to this ancient society.
The Celts did not keep their own written records,
so much of what we know about them comes from
Roman records and archeological digs.
According to the Romans, Celtic warriors often
fought naked, or, at least, with their shirts
off.
Their bodies and faces were painted with intricate
designs, which earned them the nickname “picts”,
which means “the painted people.”
They were known for being incredibly brutal.
During battle, they would begin grunting like
animals, and blew loud horns to startle their
enemies.
They beheaded the Romans without hesitation,
because they apparently believed that a man’s
head contained his power and soul.
Despite their barbaric war strategy, these
were also very intelligent people.
They were the first society to invent chainmail,
which protected them from enemy swords.
Both men and women wore gold necklaces that
included intricate designs.
Paved roads were also a Celtic invention,
even though the Romans later tried to claim
that they came up with the idea, first.
So, in a lot of ways, the Celts were far from
being the bumbling brutes that they are often
made out to be.
Boudicca was the Queen and wife of King Prasutagus,
and they were rulers of the “Iceni” tribe.
They were located in modern-day Norfolk and
Suffolk, and for a while, their people lived
in peace.
A Roman statesman and historian named Cassius
Dio describes Boudicca: “In stature she
was very tall, in appearance most terrifying,
in the glance of her eye most fierce, and
her voice was harsh.
A great mass of the tawniest hair fell to
her hips; around her neck was a large golden
necklace;
What Boudicca apparently lacked in grace and
beauty, she made up for in her brilliance.
According to Dio’s backhanded compliment,
she “possessed of greater intelligence than
often belongs to women”.
In Celtic society, “Druids” were intellectuals
and she wore a tunic of divers colours over
which a thick mantle was fastened with a brooch.”
who held very highly respected positions in
their respective tribes.
They were like priests who performed the pagan
rituals, but they also practiced medicine,
alchemy, science, and philosophy.
And yes, druids could be women, too.
Since Boudicca is remembered for being very
smart, it would make sense that she may have
been a druid in her spare time, apart from
being the Queen.
It would have only made a her a more well-respected
leader.
But with the new threat of Roman invasion,
Boudicca would need to focus on protecting
her people more than ever before.
The Roman Invasion
The Romans conquered Southern England in 43
AD. King Prasutagus could see that his Celtic
warriors were no match for the Roman Legions,
so he ordered his warriors to stop their rebellion.
Prasutagus agreed to align with the Roman
Empire for the sake of protecting what remained
of his people.
He promised that when he died, his tribe would
be under Roman rule.
In his last will and testament, he left his
land to his two daughters, and the Emperor
of Rome.
The King truly did believe that they had made
a peaceful negotiation, and the Romans even
lent the Britons their Roman currency to help
them integrate into their new society.
They were given 40,000,000 sesterces, but
they were expected to pay it back over time,
plus interest.
There is a debate over how much one sestari
would actually be actually worth in today’s
money, but the estimates are usually around
$1.50.
So their loan was roughly $60 million.
The Britons never asked for a loan in the
first place.
In fact, the Celtic tribal people were rich
in resources like gold.
But they accepted the money, anyway, because
it was the only way they could have a currency
to buy and sell together with the Romans.
Nero took Claudius’ place as the new Emperor
of Rome in the year 54.
He was just 16 years old at the time, and
he was known for spending an extravagant amount
of money.
In turn, he sought to regain much of the lost
funds by going after interest on loans, as
well as taxes.
Nero appointed a man named Suetonius Paulinus
to handle the new territory in England.
He was given the position of Governor of Britain,
and he was also the General of the Roman army.
In the year 60, King Prasutagus died, and
Queen Boudicca became the new leader of the
Icini tribe.
Of course, the Romans did not see Boudicca
as a legitimate leader, because she was a
woman.
As we mentioned earlier, there were contracts
in place before King Prasutagus’ death that
should have guaranteed his people’s safety.
But General Paulinus decided to ignore all
of it, and take the Iceni by force.
He used the loan as an excuse, and demanded
that they wanted all 40 million sesterces
to paid back in full, plus interest.
And they needed it all immediately.
The Romans went into every single home, taking
anything of value that they could find.
They captured men as slaves, and raped the
young women.
Not even the young princesses were spared.
Boudicca’s daughters were sexually assaulted
by Roman soldiers.
When she tried to rescue her daughters, the
soldiers grabbed the Queen, ripped her clothes
off, and beat her bloody in front of her people.
Since King Prasutagus truly did leave their
land to the Romans, the Celts could only stand
and watch as their beloved Queen was brutalized
in front of them.
Boudicca had been beaten, but not broken.
Instead of withering in self-pity, this attack
only sparked her need for revenge.
Boudicca called a meeting with the leaders
of the local tribes, and learned that they
had all been treated the same way.
Everyone was furious at what the Romans had
done.
The leaders of several Celtic tribes all agreed
to put aside their differences and follow
her as their new Queen.
It was clear that if the Celts wanted their
freedom, they were going to have to fight
for it.
Boudicca’s Rebellion
Boudicca had witnessed her husband’s defeat
against the Romans years earlier, and yet,
she was not afraid to fight them once again
for her people’s freedom.
Armed with a sword and her horse-drawn chariot,
Boudicca stood in front of her Celtic warriors.
Just like her men, her face would have been
adored in battle paint.
Women were fighting alongside men, and each
and every one of them had the fire of vengeance
in their hearts.
The Celts began the rebellion by targeting
the Roman city Camulodunum, which is modern-day
Colchester.
She waited until General Paulinus was out
of town, and he took his troops with him.
He was on a campaign to capture Anglesey,
which is an island in Wales.
Since he took all of his soldiers with him,
he left Camulodunum virtually undefended.
Once he was gone, Boudicca and her men entered
the city, and they slaughtered all of the
Roman men they could find.
When Roman leadership got word that they needed
help defending the city from a tribal Queen
who was leading a rebellion, they grossly
underestimated her, since she was a woman.
They sent a measly 200 unarmed slaves to take
care of the issue.
Obviously, this handful of men was nothing
compared to her massive army of 120,000 people.
An additional 2,500 Roman soldiers were sent
to help defend the city.
For several days, the soldiers tried to keep
civilians alive by hoarding themselves in
the Temple of Claudius.
The Celts grew tired of waiting, and set fire
to the temple, which trapped and killed everyone
inside.
When General Paulinus returned to Camulodunum,
he found the temple crumbling in a pile of
ash, as well as the gruesome scene of beheaded
men, dissected bodies, and pools of blood.
He knew that his small legion of just 5,000
men would be no match for Boudicca, so he
had no choice but to ride ahead to each major
Roman stronghold, and try to evacuate civilian
refugees before it was too late.
Historian Cassius Dio wrote, “All this ruin
was brought upon the Romans by a woman, a
fact which in itself caused them the greatest
shame.”
Next, the Celts moved on to “Londinium”,
which is modern-day-London, and burned the
entire city to the ground.
While in London, tribal men who had been enslaved
by the Romans were set free, and they began
to follow Boudicca.
Her army temporarily grew to over 230,000
troops.
They sacked the city of “Verulamium”,
which is modern-day St. Albans.
It is estimated that Boudicca’s army killed
and tortured between 70,000 to 80,000 Roman
people.
In the Roman history books, they describe
the Celtic slaughter as being truly barbaric.
Some modern-day historians believe that this
imagery was exaggerated in order to demonize
the Celtic culture.
Just like every other colonizing nation, the
Romans believed that they were the more civilized
ones, even though they started the fight by
attacking, robbing, and raping the Celtic
people beforehand.
Boudicca and the rest of the Celts were steadily
making progress to regain the Britons’ independence
from the Roman Empire.
At this point, Emperor Nero was seriously
considering pulling his Roman troops out of
Great Britain.
If Boudicca kept up killing his people at
such a rapid rate, she could topple the entire
empire.
And if she had succeeded, she would have gone
down in history as the queen who united the
Celtic tribes under a common cause, and regained
their independence.
But unfortunately for her, General Paulinus
was confident that he could win.
He convinced Emperor Nero to stay, because
he was ready with a strategy to take down
the resistance once and for all.
The Battle of Watling Street
The final confrontation was known as The Battle
of Watling Street.
As the name suggests, the two armies met at
a Roman road called “Watling Street.”
While there is a map of this road, most historians
disagree over the exact location, because
there is only given a brief description of
the location given by the historian Tacitus.
General Paulinus chose this location because
it was ideal for his defensive strategy.
A forest protected the back of the Roman soldiers,
so they could not be attacked from behind.
There was an open field in front of the forest,
which forced Boudicca’s army to charge straight
towards them.
As mentioned earlier, General Paulinus only
had 5,000 soldiers in his army.
He had to send letters to all of the veterans
living in Great Britain who were much older
and enjoying their retirement.
Luckily for him, an additional 5,000 men were
still loyal to the Empire, and he was able
to assemble a total of 10,000 troops.
Even after calling for backup, he was outnumbered
by Boudicca’s army.
According to the Roman historian Cassius Dio,
Queen Boudicca spent time before the battle
giving a long and riveting speech about fighting
for freedom that sounds like it’s straight
out of a Hollywood movie: "If you weigh well
the strengths of our armies you will see that
in this battle we must conquer or die.
This is a woman's resolve.
As for the men, they may live or be slaves...I
am not fighting for my kingdom and wealth
now.
I am fighting as an ordinary person for my
lost freedom, my bruised body, and my outraged
daughters."
However, Dio wasn’t even there to listen,
and there were very few witnesses who actually
survived.
So we can’t be sure if a speech was said
at all...Especially since she spends a lot
of time trying to convince her troops that
even though she’s “just” a woman, they
should still trust her, anyway.
If you think about it, a hundred thousand
Celts wouldn’t be there if they didn’t
trust her in the first place.
And archeological evidence points to proof
that the Celts gave women powerful military
positions for hundreds of years, already.
But we’ll get to that later.
The Celts had plenty of weapons and supplies
that they had scavenged from the Roman cities
they defeated, but they were still not as
well-equipped as the enemy.
Roman soldiers wore full suits of armor, helmets,
and had sandals with nails at the bottom to
help them from slipping in the grass.
They also had swords, and large shields.
Their spears could be thrown long distances,
which helped them avoid hand-to-hand combat.
Despite these setbacks, the Celtic people
were so confident that they would win the
battle, they even brought a wagon train with
their wives and children.
The wagons formed a semi-circle around the
back of the Celtic army, sealing off the exit.
According to records, General Paulinus could
see the fear in his men’s eyes as they started
at this army that was ten times larger than
theirs.
But he used insults to snap the fear out of
his men.
He tried to boost their morale by mocking
the enemy.
He said that the Celts were savages, and pointed
to the female warriors as evidence that they
were weaker than the Romans.
Just like he did with Boudicca, the historian
Cassius Dio invented yet another long and
grandiose speech for General Paulinus to say
to his troops.
While we may not be sure exactly what words
were exchanged, we do know what the general’s
battle strategy was.
He knew that even though his army had fewer
men, they were at a great advantage with their
technology.
The Roman soldiers stood side-by-side and
crouched together behind their tall shields.
During the first round of the battle, the
Celts charged towards the Romans, who threw
their spears into the air.
Without heavy metal armor to protect them,
the spears went through the chainmail and
bare chests of the Celtic warriors.
Boudicca told the men to fall back before
pressing on once more.
When the Celts pushed up against this wall
of shields, the Romans would draw their swords,
and stab the men in the chest.
Every few minutes, the Roman soldiers would
rotate, and the man who was just fighting
moved to the back of the line.
This way, each man was fresh and ready for
battle, and it gave everyone a chance to rest.
After the Celts had exhausted thousands of
their soldiers, General Paulinus gave the
order for his men to push themselves together
into a triangular formation, as their charged
towards the Celtic army.
This was an incredibly powerful metallic force
that pushed against the men, and it forced
the Celtic people to retreat.
Cassius Dio wrote, “The remainder took to
flight, although escape was difficult, as
the cordon of wagons had blocked the outlets.
The troops gave no quarter, even to the women:
the baggage animals themselves had been speared
and added to the pile of bodies.”
According to Roman records, 80,000 Celtic
men, women, and children were killed during
The Battle of Watling Street, and just 400
Romans died at the hands of Boudicca’s army.
Death and Legacy
After losing the battle, records say that
Boudicca managed to run.
While we do not know exactly what happened
next, Tacitus speculated that she would have
poisoned herself, because it would have been
the honorable thing to do at the time.
However, Cassius Dio wrote that she later
died of an illness.
Ultimately, we do not know when, or how she
died.
For years, Boudicca’s story was all but
forgotten.
Since this was such an embarrassing stain
in the Roman Empire’s history, it only makes
sense that it was buried for a long time.
But during the Renaissance, the story of the
Celtic Queen’s bravery began to emerge once
again.
She was remembered and painted by artists,
and during the Victorian Era, statues were
created in her honor.
It didn’t take long before she became a
British icon.
Despite the detailed Roman records, some people
began to wonder if she ever existed at all,
and considered the possibility that this warrior
Queen may actually be a legend.
In fact, even the named “boudīkā” comes
from the Celtic word meaning “victorious”.
At the very least, there is a chance that
Boudicca may not have been her real name,
and it was just a placeholder put in place
of her true identity.
It was in the Victorian era that Boudica's
fame took on legendary proportions as Queen
Victoria came to be seen as Boudica's "namesake",
their names being identical in meaning.
Victoria's Poet Laureate, Alfred, Lord Tennyson,
wrote a poem, "Boadicea", and several ships
were named after her.
In 2001, archeologists uncovered a burial
site of a Celtic female warrior who was laid
to rest with a huge amount of respect.
At her feet were small treasures of a mirror,
a brooch, and blue glass beads.
Her chariot was decorated with red coral gathered
from the sea.
Two other soldiers were buried next to this
woman and her chariot.
These are known as The Wetwang Graves, and
all of the artifacts from the archaeological
site are now kept at the British Museum.
According to Tony Spence, who works at the
Department of Prehistory & Europe for the
British Museum, they believe that this woman
was a Queen, because of the special care and
respect that was given to her remains.
Her chariot and the other objects surrounding
her were also so expensive, only royalty could
afford such an extravagant burial.
She would have been in her late 30’s to
early 40’s, and she was very tall.
They were able to use her skull to do a facial
reconstruction of what she would have looked
look like.
Her face was disfigured, so it’s easy to
see how she could be described as “frightening”,
like how Cassius Dio described Boudicca.
Despite the fact that nearly every detail
seems to line up with the story of Boudicca,
carbon dating done by Oxford University in
2017 placed these artifacts anywhere between
the years 145 to 200 BC, which would have
been 200-300 years before Boudicca’s battle
took place.
But scientists are now saying the carbon dating
has the potential to be wrong.
In 2018, Cornell University did an experiment
which showed proof of carbon dating that was
offset by several hundred years.
This means that many of the historic timelines
we have been taught about ancient civilizations
could actually be wrong.
Without a written record or a time machine,
we may never know the full story behind the
true identities of those people left in these
graves, and it may remain an unsolved mystery
forever.
But whether the Wetwang grave belongs to Boudicca
or not, it still proves, undoubtedly, that
the Celts included warrior women in battle.
And if they truly are 200 years before her
time, it only goes to show that in ancient
Briton, women were respected enough to lead
armies for several generations.
The remains of this warrior queen may sit
in plastic bags and cardboard boxes in a museum,
but the spirit of these leaders are still
very much alive in the hearts of everyone
who stands up against their oppressors.
Even if she was on the losing side of the
war, Boudicca truly was
a hero.